-Our first guest tonight is
a Grammy-nominated comedian
and best-selling author.
She is currently out on her
"Vaccinated and Horny" tour.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Chelsea handler,
everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
You look stunning, as always.
It's so wonderful to see you.
-Oh, it's wonderful to see you.
I had no idea Fred Armisen
was working here now.
-Isn't that wonderful?
-Yeah, hello, Fred.
-Hi, nice to see you.
-It's very nice for
a couple of our guests
to almost bring a collaboration
when they come on the show.
Obviously, you did not know
when you were coming
that Martha Stewart was going to
be on the show,
but Martha posted this photo of
herself
a couple years ago in her pool,
a very beautiful photo.
And then how quickly
did you do that?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I mean, I've always
looked up to Martha.
-Who doesn't? Yeah.
-For obvious reasons.
And it wasn't long after
I saw that shot.
I saw myself in her shot,
and I realized that I could
reproduce that pretty quickly.
-And what was her feedback?
Because she had some feedback
for you.
-Her feedback was that her pool
was a lot nicer than my pool.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, she's not lying, right?
-Well, I don't know that.
I mean, can we compare pools?
Did we get a full view
of either pool?
-I don't know.
Her pool looks super nice.
-Okay, well, it sounds like --
It sounds like you have a
favorite out of the two of us.
-I'm just saying, if you both
invited me to a pool party,
I'm, like, at Martha's house
in five minutes.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Got it. Got it. Okay.
Good to know.
-So you're touring your show,
"Vaccinated and Horny."
Feels like it's
self-explanatory,
but is there more to it?
-Well, I guess --
[ Laughter ]
I guess, you know,
it's very representative of
being single
during the pandemic.
-Right.
-Married people were dealing
with their own, you know,
set of issues,
like being married.
-Yeah.
-Or having children.
-Or having to homeschool
those children.
Single people were just -- I was
at home having a great time,
well, with my landscaper,
mostly,
because it was just the two of
us for a couple of weeks.
[ Laughter ]
And at a certain point,
it's not fun to do mushrooms
alone, so I moved him in.
-That's great.
[ Laughter ]
-And vaccinated and horny is
just how I thought the whole --
you know,
how all single people felt
as soon as we were allowed out.
And it was a dangerous time
because if all single people
get out at the same time
and start penetrating...
-Yeah.
-Then, you know, there's gonna
be, like, a new STD strain
or something like cov-erpes
or something along those lines.
[ Laughter ]
So I wanted to avoid that
but make sure everybody knew
that I was the place to come
if you were single, vaccinated,
and horny.
-That's really nice
because I'm sure, like,
those people, for the purposes
of buying the ticket,
they also get a night of
entertainment,
but also you've let them know
some important information
about yourself.
-Yes, yes, and this was before
I started my love affair
with my boyfriend, Mr. Jo Koy.
So I still am
vaccinated and horny,
but it's now directed
at one person.
-That's great.
So this is interesting,
'cause you're single
during the pandemic.
And obviously,
your boyfriend Jo,
who's also a super-talented
comedian,
but you've known him forever.
You guys met on
"Chelsea Lately."
-Uh-huh.
-Do you now, because --
Basically, you did know him
during the pandemic.
Do you look back and are you mad
that you didn't meet him
in the beginning,
just so you guys
would go through it together?
-No, I'm pretty glad that I went
through that pandemic
mostly solo.
-Okay.
-I mean, my sister did come
and invade my house
with her three children,
which is something I've worked
pretty hard
to avoid my whole life.
-Yeah.
-So that was a slight hiccup.
But I think the pandemic was
better, if you could do it solo,
I think it was a good thing
to do solo.
-I've heard you. I believe you
and I have even talked about
your sister
and her three children,
and you have often framed it
as an invasion.
And I'm wondering --
-Yeah, it was a home invasion.
That's what I call it.
I sold that house.
Actually, I put it on the market
while they were still
living there, to send a message.
[ Laughter ]
And I promptly sold that house.
I moved out of that house,
and I bought a new house
and I have converted any extra
bedroom into something
that is not a bedroom.
[ Laughter ]
-So not even something like
a home gym that you could turn
into a bedroom for the weekend?
-No.
No, I don't have
any extra bedrooms.
And my sister is like,
"That seems pretty drastic.
You have a pretty big family."
And I'm like, "Well, these are
the new rules."
You know, we vacation together
a couple times a year.
I think that's plenty.
-Yeah.
How do the kids feel about
their aunt
referring to them
as home invaders?
-They're used to me
because they've known me
since they were born.
So they know that
they're just lucky
I'm not saying anything worse,
you know?
But actually, that's not true
because in my stand-up show,
I do talk about my nephew a lot.
I was a little bit worried
about that
because as a public figure,
when you talk about your family,
they can be very sensitive
about that.
And it's hard. It's a conflict
because it's like,
it's my story, too.
-Yeah.
-So I --
-Yeah, that would be like
Chelsea erasure if you're not
allowed to talk about it.
-Yeah, right.
-How old is he?
-He's 24.
-Oh, that's okay. Come on.
-Yeah, right.
-I mean, you're talking about
a nephew, I think a lot of us
are like,
"That poor 7-year-old."
-Yeah.
-Yeah, just in case,
his name is Jake Hutchinson.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
So if people want to Facebook
him and verify the age.
-Just in case you want to find
out more about him,
that's his name.
-I have a lot more questions
for you.
We'll be right back with more
from Chelsea Handler.